we've got breaking news from London
where a new Prime Minister has just been
named Boris Johnson will officially
replace outgoing Prime Minister charissa
made tomorrow this was expected charlie
daggers outside the houses of parliament
with more on this story so Charlie what
can you tell us about Britain's new
leader yeah well we're just in and it
looks like a landslide a lot of people
here are saying that this is a role that
Boris Johnson has waited his entire life
for and the leader of America's closest
ally may be a familiar face to many
Americans now by a quirk of British
politics Boris Johnson was not elected
by the general public but instead chosen
to lead by members of his own
Conservative Party making him a prime
minister voted him by less than one
percent of the electorate now he
replaces the beleaguered Teresa May who
is forced to step aside after repeatedly
failing to deliver a deal for Britain to
leave the European Union now johnson has
often stressed the importance of having
a close relationship with the US and
this change of leadership comes at a
critical time with a British tanker in
the hands of the Iranians and both the
British and American military's boosting
up their presence in the region now as
former Mayor of London Johnson once
accused President Trump of stupefying
ignorance and being unfit for office but
he has recently softened his tone but
his brand of bombast brashness and
frankly bad hair has earned him a
reputation as something of a political
renegade now among his biggest
challenges coming up of course Briggs it
you can see for yourself out there and
it's not going to be easy a number of
top ministers have already said they're
going to resign the moment he takes
office Tony all right Charlie I'll take
it from here thank you very much Charlie
d'Agata in London